please help me welcome to the stage Gary
Vaynerchuk good afternoon uh actually
there's a lot of different places I want
to take this talk so I think I'll use
the context of this first question to
navigate my content and then I'll
pontificate and then we will do some QA
because I think the details are far more
interesting than the hyperbole or the
context that I roll with up here and
obviously a lot of it you can gather
through YouTube and other places so
quickly by show of hands how many of you
have no idea who I am please raise your
hand that [ __ ] hurts touchstart I
figured that to be the case so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to give you a
background on where I came from and and
then we'll take it from there so I was
born in the former Soviet Union I was
born in Belarus I came to the US when I
was three we were very poor I lived in a
studio apartment in Queens that was
about the size of this stage my dad got
a bunch of side jobs one was a stock boy
in a liquor store in Clark New Jersey
where where he made two bucks an hour
and and that's where our American Dream
started my dad eventually became the
manager of that store and we moved to
Edison New Jersey where my
entrepreneurial career began when I was
six I started a six lemonade stand
franchise so how many of you by show of
hands remember big wheels those little
bikes I would I rode my big wheels at
the end of the day picking up my cash
like I was little Tony Soprano or
something so that was good that was a
good start to like start making some
money when I was I when I turned 13 I
started my real first big business
baseball cards were a big deal
when when I was of that age in the US
and I started selling baseball cards in
the in the malls of New Jersey making
two to three thousand dollars a weekend
as a 14-year old as you can imagine
that's pretty big-time I don't know
about you guys but when you have thirty
thousand dollars in cash under your bed
and you're 14 and you're not selling
weed you're doing a good job so so that
was good
and then at that point my dad you know
how many people you're immigrants or a
child of an immigrant raise your hands
makes sense so as you guys know
intimately when you're an immigrant you
don't spend any money on anything and
eventually you can buy your own business
and that's what my dad did he eventually
bought a small liquor store in
Springfield New Jersey called shoppers
discount liquors and when I turned 14 I
had the privilege of going from making a
thousand dollars a weekend to making two
bucks an hour bagging ice for 15 hours a
day and I did at every weekend and ever
every single summer vacation of my life
for two years I call those the dark ages
eventually my dad allowed me to come
upstairs and and that's where I really
learned my passion of the business my
dad was and at that point I wasn't super
interested in selling
Coors Light or or Absolut Vodka there
was nothing interesting about it people
bought what they bought we sold those
items that cost we were to discount
liquor retailer
I couldn't get my juices going but wine
culture was just starting in the US in
the mid 90s and we were in Springfield
New Jersey so sumit Milburn Short Hills
some affluence around us so there was
some wine build-up happening then I
became super interested in and because
people collected wine that was really my
attachment point of the wine collecting
to the baseball card and comic book all
that kind of stuff for me was kind of
like you know Michael Jordan Frank
Thomas Wayne Gretzky silver oak Opus one
Chateau Lafite same [ __ ] I can do this
so so I basically moved all my attention
of learning that world
versus the baseball card world this is
where the story starts making a
connection point between a lot of you
and myself I will make this statement
predicated on what I'm about to talk
about for the next forty or so minutes
before we get into Q&A and I think it's
going to make a very important
connection point between all of us
there's one thing I really want you to
understand as I go on with this talk I
love social media because it sells [ __ ]
not because it's interesting I don't
like tech eNOS I didn't grow up with a
computer until I was 18 years old I like
it
because it sells stuff and that's the
important connection that I want to
really make here see my career took an
interesting turn at 18 I decided that I
was going to open up 4,000 liquor stores
I used to call it the Toys R Us of
liquor stores and wine shops across the
country build the biggest franchise in
the wine and spirits world sell it and
buy the New York Jets right that was the
game plan and that's still the game plan
but it's taken a very different turn and
it's first turn happened my freshman
year in college I was in my dorm room
playing Madden 94 dominating by the way
and my friend ran into my room and said
hey man you have to come and see this I
run into a room there's six guys
hovering over a computer now mind you
I've spent less than 10 hours on a
computer in my life at this point I was
a crap student so I mailed in computer
class and I think I had a word processor
that I never opened to do my papers and
so I'm sitting in front of this computer
it's the first time that I ever hear
couch
remember that I want to talk about the
real racket dial-up internet three bucks
a minute
[ __ ] AOL anyway
they're sitting there I'm hovering over
him I make a very profound statement I
say is this the information superhighway
that's what we called it back then I
know you guys know and and there was the
internet I waited an hour and a half to
my turn
shows you how different the web was when
an hour and a half for my turn to
navigate the web and the first seven
minutes I landed on a wat on a baseball
card bulletin board where people were
selling baseball cards back and forth
and literally in that instance I
realized holy crap I do not need to open
up 4,000 wine shops I can use this thing
to sell more wine
in 1996 about 18 months later I launched
the second ecommerce wine retail
business in America called
winelibrary.com in 1998 I took over
operations from my dad's store from 1996
to 1998 while still in school the
business ran in the first year that we
did winelibrary.com we did less than
five thousand dollars in net sales on
the website now I don't know how many of
you have a Soviet father but Sasha
Vaynerchuk wasn't super happy with the
ROI on the $25,000 investment
we stopped it over here I'm gonna try to
stay away from it
in 1998 I took over my dad's business it
did three million dollars in revenue on
ten percent gross profit so we're
talking about three hundred thousand
dollars to the bottom line
luckily Sasha paid nobody so we took a
couple bucks home from 1998 to 2003 in a
five-year window with no cash infusion I
grew that business from a three to a
sixty million dollar business right so I
sit in a room that I very much associate
with I live in Silicon Valley world I
live in Madison Avenue world but this
room is my favorite world these are you
guys are operators you run your business
you can I can talk about anything you
want we could talk about Facebook and
Twitter and all this stuff
there's one very simple basic thing in a
60 month period I grew a business from
three to sixty million dollars in
revenue on one very simple fact that
99.9% of these businesses in this room
do not follow which is I operated and
more importantly marketed in the year
that I actually lived in let me explain
what I did that's a very simple thing is
I played the arbitrage of customer
acquisition and also real quick while I
tell these stories I recognize that this
was a b2c business and I also recognize
there's a lot of b2b businesses in there
just to give you context I now currently
run a 600 person social and digital
agency that four years ago was 30 people
and I've grown the business from a three
to a sixty five million dollar business
and those three and a half years I'm
going to do 100 million dollars in
revenue next year it's a runway it's a
very simple blueprint which is the
following
there is always an arbitrage of where
you could be marketing your business
whether in a b2b or b2c environment
however most people don't execute and
market in the year that they actually
live in 99 percent of the businesses in
this room are marketing like it's 2007
2004 2001 1996 there's some [ __ ] in
here from the 1980s
in that white space I live I live in the
white space while everybody else debates
the ROI of these new things in 1996 that
was email marketing I had one of the
first email newsletters going how many
people here in this room have ever been
close enough have ever run email
marketing run email marketing or a close
enough in your business right now where
you understand your email marketing
raise your hands higher just for context
please great just for all of you that
are close to it in 1996 I had an email
newsletter that had hundreds of
thousands of people on it that had a 90
plus percent open rate yeah Wow
because in 1996 and you guys are old so
you [ __ ] remember I'm old too I'm 39
I talk to a lot of kids that's why I'm
singing in 1996 how many people got on
email in 1996 raise your hand just
curious you remember well yeah I know
there's some nerds in here relax but in
1996 we read every goddamn email it's
what we did it was new I remember
sending email cuz I couldn't believe it
was free and I didn't realize that it
would be free forever I literally was
like they're gonna charge for this [ __ ]
because I'm never sending a letter again
how are they gonna subsidize those you
know costs government [ __ ] but anyway
the bottom line is very simply that's
what worked for me then having the first
e-commerce wine business worked for me
then I set a room like this in Jersey
Chamber of Commerce on route 22 in Union
New Jersey in 1996 telling everybody
that I was going to sell wine on the
Internet the opening I give my whole
spiel the opening question from somebody
in the audience is Carrie I'm very
confused by this thing explain to me so
you're telling me at the Wine Library
which I know I know you're on Melbourne
Avenue you're gonna take a bottle of
wine and you're gonna stick it in a wire
and it's gonna show up at somebody's
house this was literally this was
literally the discussion in 1996 about
internet people everybody told me in
1996 seven eight nine that people
wouldn't buy stuff first people didn't
think people would buy anything on the
internet then it wasn't wine by show of
hands and this is very important I know
a lot of you want to mail it
in and head nod and I just asked you a
show of hands and you guys all [ __ ]
it I need high hands because I want
everybody see this and remember the
following question lying is the devil
all right here we go by show of hands
how many people remember very easily
just 15 years ago or less you being very
uncomfortable and even made the
statement that you would not put a
credit card in to a computer don't lie
raise your hands raise it high Jesus now
all those people how many of you have
now put a credit card into a web site
raise your hands that my friends what
just happened is the single place where
I live that right there that right there
what you in this room right now think
you won't do and what I know you're
going to do is the white space in which
I will buy the [ __ ] New York Jets and
that has been the calling card and that
is what I'm trying to inspire one
because I'm very practical you're about
to get pumped I'm gonna make a lot of
sense because I'm a businessman I don't
care about technology I wish it didn't
exist I knew exactly how to do direct
mail and radio and print I did those
things I don't want things to change I
figured out email marketing and Google
Adwords
how many will here run Google AdWords
for their business raise your hands I
bought the word wine the day it came out
for five cents a click and known did for
nine months before anybody bid me up
white space white space market in the
year that you live in I know that every
b2b manufacturer in this room right now
can sell a ton more [ __ ] by running
Facebook dark post ads right now and
they have no idea for that to be true
because they're a headline reader and
they're not a practitioner you read to
[ __ ] articles in the Wall Street
Journal and you form your opinion and
you have no [ __ ] idea what you're
talking about
so how do I move somebody to this mental
place in this talk I give you real-life
examples I talk about real stuff I also
recognize that this is going to be fun
and cool and interesting and blah blah
blah
and the next Thursday happens and you
lose a deal or somebody quits and you go
back to real life and you go on defense
instead of offense
this and kudos to you for getting out of
the day to day operations is where you
need to go on the offense but this is
where you need to make religious beliefs
instead of tactics the reason most
people don't win in these spaces is
they're trying to win on tactics versus
the religion and here is the religion my
friends we are living through right now
the greatest shift in human
communications since the printing press
and it's 5x the change of that we are
living right now through the biggest
shift in the way that we communicate
that we've ever seen guys how many
people in this room have sent an emoji
via text in the last year raise your
hands
grown ass 70 year old dudes sending poop
grown ass 70 year old men sending poop
via text on a phone think about that
cuz here's what's happened here's what's
happened how many people here are lucky
enough to have a 15 to 25 year old child
or grandchild in their lives raise your
hands this is gonna be perfect you guys
remember three years ago when you had
this awesome conversation hey little
Ricky hey little Suzy I don't give a
crap how you talk with your friends but
when your mother and father call you
pick up the damn phone remember that
just curious how'd that work out for you
I'll help you answer that question
they're a grown-ass men in here who
texted oMG and lol today how many people
in this room in every 24-hour window
including when they're sleeping are
always within arm's reach of this raise
your hands high I want everybody see it
look at them everybody hold it up people
in the front hold it up I see some hands
that went down please I just wanted to
be see this every 24-hour window within
arm's reach of this my friends this is
the first second third and fourth screen
in people's lives this is the most
important thing in the world is the
closest extension to your brain in the
world I would rather somebody roll up on
me stab me in the stomach and steal my
wallet then lose my phone and so here's
one thing this stitch that I can tell
you regardless of what you do for a
living every one of you is connected by
one truth that matters to every goddamn
person in this room which is before you
tell me how great your business is and
what you can do for me as a service
provider or you can sell me some tools
or you're a great agency before you tell
me or any other consumer what your thing
is and why it's so great you need the
most important commodity in the world
attention you need somebody's attention
before you can tell them how good your
thing is and what we're doing now more
than ever is wasting real big money as a
collective industries on places where
people are not paying attention to as
much and that is the rub that is the
opportunity we are not spending our
marketing and storytelling prowess where
people are actually living in 2015 and
we're spending on places that we've
always done it that we know is
tried-and-true it's how we've done it
we're being very romantic about how we
get there and that is the opportunity at
hand
friends I run a big agency now Pepsi
Unilever GE Toyota big big big big
brands the collective fortune 500
industry is spending 80 billion dollars
producing television commercials and
distributing them by show of hands how
many people in this room now when they
watch their favorite TV show takeaway
sports now when you watch your favorite
television show you watch it on your
time not when it actually airs Netflix
HBO GO
DVR you watch your favorite TV show on
your time raise your hands high
show me Oh weird everybody this isn't
the 14 to 23 year old crowd and if
you're lucky enough that your remote
control falls off your bed so you can't
fast-forward and a commercial actually
comes every person in this room grabs
their phone and checks their email
yet yet we are spending 80 billion
dollars and you don't give a rat's ass
that a Jeep is going up a hill right you
don't care for [ __ ] and we're throwing
good money directly in the trash how
many people here who can't wait to leave
this great conference how many people
here can't wait to get home tonight from
the Vistage conference and check their
mail carefully and go through that
billions of dollars that are spent on
direct mail to sell you something and
what about outdoor media billions of
dollars spent on billboards to sell us
stuff
if you drive home from this conference
please look at five if you remember
anything from this talk go outside now
when you go home and look at five people
driving I promise you every passenger is
looking at their phone all attention
that used to be there ten years ago
that's gone [ __ ]
three out of the five drivers are
looking at their phone
so people are looking at billboards
they're barely looking at the [ __ ]
road as an effect since the first time
since I was 16 I'm driving with both
hands because I'm scared of you guys cuz
you're literally looking at your phone
at all times and by the way this is not
a traditional versus digital thing how
many people here click the banner ad in
the last year I mean nobody does that
it's on the bottom left hand corner of a
website nobody wants that pre-roll
videos that make you watch a video for
30 seconds that you have no interest in
because you wanted to see something else
not value stealing from us I made an
early investment in a company called
uber that's good but I passed on uber
angel round and left hundreds of
millions of dollars on the table which
is a real Mis for me it's because I
didn't understand what goober was really
selling the first time around when I
passed in the next round I made a
connection my brother took the first
uber in New York City because we're very
friendly with the founder and CEO and we
were testing it and I realized holy crap
uber doesn't sell transportation uber
sells time my friends we are living
through a 24/7 365 world everybody here
is how many people remember working
pre-internet just raise your hands
that's right you guys have real context
remember actually you even if you were a
workaholic you work 9:00 to 8:00 p.m. at
least the day was over there's none of
that anymore we're all on 24/7 365 which
means time has become our number one
asset we value it immensely
we will spend for it tremendously and
that is why you BIR has one direct how
many people here have taken an uber in
New York City tri-state area while
waiting for the uber have watched yellow
cabs drive right by that literally uber
sells the perception of time and we go
for it this is important for you to
think about the following people that do
sales in this room a lot of people do
sales there's a big conversation between
sales and marketing in my mind always
because they matter so much and they
both matter and so many of these
companies in this room in the market
live on sales and don't think enough
about marketing which then becomes a
more
time value higher level can save you a
lot of cost on sales and more
importantly sales are changing how many
people in this room are willing to admit
the following this is intense how many
people are willing to admit the
following I need you here how many
people are now mad when another human
being
calls them raise your hand raise it high
I want everybody see this raise it high
high I want you guys to look around keep
it up for a second I see you later you
dropping it because I think a lot of
people don't understand this phenomenon
this happening this is about 50% of the
room my friends let me just say this one
more time
I just passed a room full of 700 people
how many people were mad when any human
being calls them ever and they're mad
they're mad because they understand
technology has gotten to a place where
that doesn't have to be the case they're
mad because you could have texted me and
I could get back to you on my time not
you bothering me on your time mom and so
we've lived for 70 years we're marketing
and advertising and sales have been in
the business of disrupting you when
you're doing your [ __ ] and trying to
sell you I want to listen to the
ballgame they're gonna stop and sell me
some beer I'm listening to a great radio
show they stop they try to sell
something I'm reading a very good
article I turn the page wait it's a
full-page ad for a car I got to get
around it right I want to go to a
website a banner ad pops up I've got to
click it get out of the way and then
read what I want we have been in
disruptive marketing so I call you in
your house and try to tell a market to
you right this has been the game for 70
years and there's a problem the problem
is technology has finally caught up to
the actual consumer behavior it started
with boo-booed with them Tibo and it's
moving on to every technology in the
world including the next update for
Apple where they're blocking ads on your
mobile device because I think we all
know there's nothing worse there's
literally nothing worse than a pop-up
banner ad on a mobile device because as
you guys know it takes a
the whole goddamn screen I don't know if
you've noticed the X is so minuscule
I don't know about you guys my thumb is
fattest [ __ ] I try to I try to X out I
miss I click it it takes me to the wrong
page it steals 4 seconds of my time
which is really goddamn valuable at this
point cuz the way we live and back home
at media agency world or at the brand
and the look look how good the click
through ratio is meanwhile you hate that
brand meanwhile after that happened to
me 500 times on ESPN I call my wife I
said no more Samsung products as long as
I when I'm dead Lizzy do your own thing
but I'm telling you right now
no more Samsung products because the
sentiment was negative not positive I
know that we help companies like GE sell
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
lighting contracts by running ads
against employees of cost companies that
actually could buy that lighting
contract I know that if you use LinkedIn
Twitter and Facebook properly one sales
person can drive the sales results that
a 10 person sales team can do for your
business if you actually knew how it
worked I know that nobody understands
that right this second Facebook ads is
the single best ad product since early
Google AdWords and the only point of
view that people have on it was the
organic reach went away and they tricked
us to sell us ads yet not recognizing
it's the best ROI ad product of all time
and number two the kids aren't their
cool
agreed but [ __ ] a lot of people here
don't need to be selling to 15 year olds
so I know that you've heard of social
media and you hear of it as social media
that thing and I hear in as social media
the slang term for the current state of
the internet and when you take that
definition and understand the current
state of the internet it gets a lot
harder in this room to bet against it
a lot of it against the Internet knock
yourself is out it's a bad idea because
if you sit here calmly actually this is
a very important conversation to have
right now because I want to navigate off
of this show of hands how many people in
this room are retiring in the
next five years and I don't mean you're
gonna [ __ ] kill it and buy a boat I
mean I mean you're old and you're
[ __ ] finished so one more time but
one more time how many people retiring
here in the next five years raise your
hands one two three okay great so for
you six gentlemen I think you can take
some of the you know content that I'm
about to roll out with with some grain
of salt
you know really hope you enjoyed the
fishing and whatever the [ __ ] you're up
to um but for the rest of you please
remember that ten years ago today
nothing that matters in attention today
existed not smartphones Facebook YouTube
or they just turn ten LinkedIn Twitter
Instagram snapchat my friends this is
the number one thing in the world
this right here fifty percent of what
people do on this thing is social
networks attention attention you think
that your customers not on it because
you've aged down the platforms you think
it's 20 year olds how many people in
this room on Facebook raise your hands
Oh weird interesting yeah how many
people in this room on Instagram raise
your hands
hmm more do people would have thought
because what we're living through back
to that culture shift if you're bought
into this religion not the tactic what
we're living through my friends is
something very very fascinating which is
the age downa fication
of our society let me explain if you are
lucky enough to be in this room right
now and can sit here and know your age
and if you were lucky enough to know
your parent at your exact age that you
are now if you're blessed enough to have
known your parent at the age that you
are right the second how many people
have that raise your hands now think
about your parent at your age right now
how much goddamn older they
more than you are acting now we are
acting so much younger in one generation
as a matter of fact if you look at the
consumer behavior
the average 42 year-old woman is acting
like most 29 year old females only a
decade ago the number one growth of
selfies on Instagram is 40 to 50 year
old females cougar
selfies cougar selfies
early in Facebook when I spoke in rooms
like this in 2009 and I said you're
gonna be on Facebook you know that whole
spiel I did with raise your hand so yeah
I know
I would segue into how many people here
are not on Facebook a lot of people
raise your hands I would say you're
gonna be on it they would be like No
then I would ask actually let's ask it
here how many people in this room at one
point in her lives probably seven eight
years ago said that they would never go
on Facebook why would they do that and
have now gone on Facebook raise your
hands tell the truth so that was the
game I would play right and so to me
what people didn't understand back then
I used to call it the grandma effect
which was I was living in the age where
I knew people were putting their kids
pictures on Facebook and if you wanted
to keep up with your kids that's where
you had to be period than the story it's
the biggest reason so many people in
this room are on Instagram now because
that's where their kids are spending
their time on theirs even how many
people in this room are on snapchat
raise your hands high let's clap it up
for these pioneers good [ __ ] and I know
some of the old folks are here like
isn't that the site where they send the
penis pictures and the sex I know that's
what old white men put on media to scare
you away from these things it's the
place where 125 million people go every
single day and spend multiple hours now
those people right now are 14 to 25 year
olds those same people will be 25 to 35
year olds in about oh I don't know 12 to
18 months those people that make
business decisions those people that
influence people within their
organizations to make business decisions
and it might make sense for you to have
some goddamn clue of what's going on
there if that's going to be the case and
that's the theory and that's the basic
principle which is if you sit in this
room right now and you run a business
that does seven figures a year and you
have zero knowledge of what's going on
on Facebook and Instagram and snapchat
and Twitter and Pinterest depending on
your business if you have zero knowledge
and you have a seven-figure business in
b2b or b2c
you as a CEO are not positioning your
business in the right manner you are
making yourself very very vulnerable
because this shift is real because
technology doesn't care about how you
want the world to be it just does it the
way it's going to be some poor sap
bought five thousand horses before Henry
Ford created the car
he lost the price went down on that
commodity because technology changed
Woolworths and JC Penney's and Sears
didn't innovate they lost iBM is in deep
trouble because of cloud services and
then adjust but Amazon did and the world
goes on and on and on and my friends
with all due respect to everybody in
this room including myself way better
way bigger businesses than ours have
gone out of business by disrespecting
the year that we live in how many people
here are in mana fit in manufacturing
raise your hands I mean look I assume
you're paying a little attention to
what's going on with 3d printing like ya
got to like you wanted us disrespect it
you're more than welcome if you deploy
technology growth over a 10-year window
it's very difficult to understand why in
the world 15 years from this moment
right now anybody would buy a
screwdriver or a part of any sorts when
they can print it in their home your
head can't totally wrap itself around
that because we didn't grow up with it
but nor did your great great you went
and dug up your great-great-grandfather
and showed him this world he would [ __ ]
his pants
they would say what the hell is this and
that and this and that do you know that
the number one new construction feature
on suburban homes in 2015 is a door on
the front door of homes so that people
can drop the amazon packages right
behind it guys
we you know I I questioned myself you
know what's really most interesting to
me is that all of you know these things
are happening in real life oh let me
just raise your hands yeah half of you
don't want a phone call from another
person right you're sending emojis to
each other you didn't know what an emoji
was 24 months ago right you're all your
behaviors from an everyday basis the way
you live as a human being have shifted
on you yet you're trying to run your
business as if it doesn't exist in
today's environment of communication
this is a major opportunity as it is a
major risk and you're more than welcome
to put your head in the sand
and I'll tell you this the number one
quickest way to go out of business is to
be romantic about how you make your
money you're more than welcome to draw a
line in the sand you're more than
welcome to be super sad that when you go
out to a restaurant and you see a couple
sitting there and they're both on the
phone you're more than welcome to judge
them how sad that is right you're more
than welcome to judge your grandkids or
your nieces and nephews or your own kids
about how they just sit at home and play
Minecraft and their fat asses because
they don't go outside or how this is my
favorite this is my favorite old person
talking I'm talking like my 30 year old
friends oh these kids they don't even
know how to communicate to each other
because they're always on the phone
right they don't know how to communicate
meanwhile what you were doing on that
same Tuesday afternoon 30 years old
earlier was you were outside throwing a
tennis ball against the wall playing
wall ball by yourself and more
importantly which way more interesting
to me is where the hell do you think the
world's going like what do you think
your kids and these youngsters lives are
going to look like in a digital era you
think we're going backwards you think
everyone's gonna melt their phones
and like we're gonna be anti-technology
this is going in one direction and what
what I'm passionate about and what I
have fear for is the level of disrespect
for how big of a shift this really is
and how intense it changes your
industries my friends when I invested in
uber I called my dad as a dad you need
to talk to Lenny and Nicolai Viktor and
Ivan because all my dad's friends when
they came to America a lot of them went
to LA how many people have lived in LA
or spent time in LA so as you guys
probably know if you've spent time there
every single black car in LA is driven
by a Russian dude right so they set up
shop there in the 70s and 80s these are
good guys they're 62 63 years old and my
dad's friends I call my dad I said
listen this Eber thing is real because
it Buber just for your own knowledge it
happened fast it was very quickly like
holy crap what the hell's San Francisco
did more in the first three months than
they projected for two years so you got
something here right so clomid I said
look dad these guys need to sell their
business my dad has seen me be write a
lot sends me that way these guys laughed
me out of the phone they said let me get
this straight
daddy people are gonna pick up people
randomly in their cars through their
phone you're such a nice boy here's the
interesting thing in 36 months and this
this is not a fun story - these are guys
that came to America in the late 70s
worked as a cab driver for seven or
eight years every day of their lives
built up money bought their own cars and
medallions built the business work their
asses off have now just hit 62 63 maybe
bought a boat to go in the Revue finally
ready to like cash in either sell the
business or have somebody else in the
family run it collect dividends and
literally their businesses are worth a
quarter on the dollar in 36 months I
mean do you think that the Hilton and
the Marriott and Four Seasons five years
ago when they sat in a room five years
ago sat a room and said okay what's
gonna happen in hotel industry who's
gonna what's the Westin this really said
what's the West's thing gonna do Hilton
said what do you think Marriott's gonna
do nobody in that [ __ ]
meeting razor hands and says you know
what I think is going to happen is a
platform is going to come out where
people put their apartments and homes on
it and everybody just buys it off each
other I think I'm gonna call it Airbnb
nobody said that nobody said that five
years ago it didn't exist and that is
now the disproportionate biggest
hospitality company in the world how
many people in this room have used an
Airbnb raise your hands raise your hands
high you know what raise your hands high
for a second isn't one everybody sees
I'll be honest with you and I'm in this
[ __ ] this is what I do 24/7
raise your hands kill one more time I
apologize I don't bothering you that's a
lot I'm surprised
wait a minute how many people on
Instagram raise your hands
all right that's [ __ ] up we need more
Instagram stuff like that makes no sense
on the ratio meter guys almost half this
room just raised their hand that they
used an Airbnb every one of those
dollars used to go to the Marriott and
the Four Seasons and the Ritz and
somebody else we are really really
really living through a culture shift
that everybody's disproportionately
under estimating and let me tell you the
quickest and easiest way for you to
address it in your world how many people
here spend money on marketing in any
shape or form
raise your hands every one of you has to
go look at every line item on your P&L
of what you spend on marketing I promise
you forty to sixty percent of the money
you spend to make more money is going
directly in the garbage cuz your
marketing like it's a decade ago and as
a matter of fact I know this because I
do this for a living at scale most of
you don't even know the practitioner
details in that spend it's just the way
it is you've taken for granted what it
does you do not know the current ro eyes
of your AdWords campaign your direct
mail campaign your platforms your
sponsorships your flyers your radio
whatever it is you're doing and so while
this is all happening in this entire
room is spending their money's on those
places people are tuning out those
messages be buying buying an ad in a
print magazine
I mean really because somebody's going
to go to page 132 of the b2b magazine in
your industry and see your full-page ad
and get inspired to call you I mean we
are wasting real [ __ ] money hundreds
of collective billions of dollars each
year being thrown directly in the trash
because people are not practitioners in
the reality of the current marketplace
and so I implore you and by the way I
know what you're thinking huh this guy
might be right yeah I'm gonna take that
twenty four-year-old in my office and
put him on this do not [ __ ] do that
most of your twenty four year olds that
are pushing social media as an agenda
they're practitioner ship on social
media is about picking up chicks or
dudes or hanging out it is not
predicated on actually selling stuff
there's real tangible ROI in these
platforms we have many b2b companies
send selling million dollar contracts
through a post on Twitter or Facebook or
LinkedIn real money because you're on
them and please how many people on
LinkedIn here we go everybody this is
not a social media strategy go to
LinkedIn and spam [ __ ] that you want
to sell to that is not a strategy of
emailing them cold and saying I'm Pam
work with me it's not going to work
I mean I mean again because I look at
the data of inbound versus outbound you
don't respond to the spamming you get
unlike then yet you deploy it as if you
think everybody's different than you my
friends it's time to wake up it's 2016
and the far majority of this room is not
playing like it is and you're putting
your head in the sand if you don't think
this stuff is going to really shift
stuff and your emerging competitors
either the ones in this room the three
the two that it get inspired from here
and do something about it or the 15 to
20 that never knew the way you did it
and are just starting and doing it the
only way they know which is this way how
many people here are familiar with
Birchbox Birchbox raise your hand
Birchbox company I wrote the first check
in two zero two four hundred million
dollars in revenue of a subscription of
the month makeup business in four years
meanwhile and by the way Pinterest
Instagram Facebook meanwhile L'Oreal is
a client of mine I go sit down with the
CEO the other day he goes Gary we're
really struggling for twenty to thirty
five year olds you've been saying this
is a problem help me understand help me
understand I said okay
Fredrik I go for the last eighteen
months I've been trying to explain to
you that if you think that you're gonna
reach twenty to thirty five year old
women by buying page 197 in Vogue and
spending stick with me now seven hundred
million dollars in print advertising
you're out of your goddamn mind and
that's it and so that's Lori yells
extreme and I know nobody here spending
seven hundred million in advertising on
print but they're trying to capture
people's attention in a place that we
left a long time ago my friends this is
historic this is history repeating
itself if you want to be a practitioner
if you want to be as a story and go read
go get yourself educated on the carnage
the carnage that happened when the radio
went for
being the number one platform to being
number two behind television and all the
brands that were romantic and emotional
about loving the radio and they love the
guy that read their ad for them and they
grew up listening to the ballgame on the
radio so [ __ ] this thing called TV go
read the stories about that and
understand we're living through that
again we're not going back it's not
happening so wake up because you have a
lot to lose and the most interesting
part is if you actually wake up and
become a practitioner and educated you
have a lot to gain a whole lot so please
mark it and operate like it's 2015-16
because when you start marketing that
way you start operating that way and you
start realizing maybe you need to treat
your employees differently
I run a 600 person firm where I spend
70% of my time on HR I'm gonna head of
HR that's what I am I run an agency I
sell people the hell am I going to spend
my time on and we are now living in a
place where your workforce has more
options than it's ever had before and if
we're not bringing value to our people
if you're not following every one of
your employees on social media to get a
context of who they are and what they
are outside of your four walls you're
making a huge mistake
- one of the best things I do now cures
my workforce skews very young I respect
that some of yours won't or won't have
you but the bottom line is we need to do
way more about caring about the number
one asset we have which is our employees
my customers are a distant second to my
employees and with all the changes that
are going on in this marketplace guys
you know this everybody coming out of
college right now thinks that they're
the next Mark Zuckerberg every 23
year-old in America right now is trying
to raise two million dollars under
[ __ ] [ __ ] idea and a lot of
people in this room raided wrote a
$25,000 check to their friend's son
because he's going to do the next uber
and so really being very very
interesting times and so what I can tell
you practically is the disproportional
ROI of my financial career has been
predicated on investing
my people and using the current
technologies I've never been able to
scale it better I have a better read and
understanding who they are and how they
roll and you start using these tools and
this shift in so many different ways
I really really implore you to take this
seriously because if you think a lot
changed in the last 10 years wait to see
what happens in the next 10 years are
you guys ready for smart pants cuz smart
phones are here right we can all agree
that got smart are you guys ready for
smart pants let me tell you what smart
pants are you put your pants on in the
morning cool you're running through life
you're busy you go to a fast-food joint
you order a burger you go to pay for it
now with this on an everyday basis so
five years from now paying with this
wallet no more you got to pay for it
it declines and your smart pants text
you stop eating burgers get a salad
badass
it's all coming smart refrigerator you
know disrupted that's going to be for
CPG brands your smart refrigerator in
your kitchen knowing that you're a Bud
Light drinker
then when you're down to one bud light
it reorders it for you and so who's
gonna make that sale Walmart I don't
think so my wine shop I don't think so
Bud Light the Internet is the middleman
many of you won't see it all the way
through to disrupt your business but
that's only going to happen out of luck
you got lucky that you didn't own a
hotel you got lucky that you didn't own
a black car service but right now right
this second one of the businesses in
this room is being disrupted by two kids
with an idea with tons of money and
backing and the internet as its
infrastructure to speed up from zero to
a pain-in-the-ass to a [ __ ] problem
in 24 months and if you don't start
running the marathon at at least at
least I can't help ask you to do what I
try to do every day which is try to put
myself out of business every day I wake
up I try to put myself out of business
because it's much more fun if I do it
then somebody else does it for me and I
can't ask you to do that because that's
a big leap from not being deep in it but
what I can ask this room is to start
looking at their advertising and start
acting like it's 2016 because that would
become a proxy to all your behavior both
in HR both in operations both in product
both in everything it's the quickest and
most practical way to be there I love
when people position me in media I was
on Bloomberg TV today thought leader
guru this tenet I'm the most practical
person I was born with zip when I was
doing my marketing there was no awards
there was no reports like many of you if
I didn't sell more Pinot Grigio that was
the problem so all this stuff I'm
telling you I'm gonna [ __ ] futurist
I'm not here to get you excited I'm here
to wake you the [ __ ] up I'm practical
[ __ ] it's 2015 wake up
thank you
thank you thank you so what I would look
that's great rah rah but I wanted to cut
it short I want to go deep into QA
please come with social media 101 very
practical stuff don't be shy I got a
list of a lot of the people that were in
this room in the businesses 99 percent
of you suck [ __ ] so so nobody's gonna be
embarrassed we're all in the same place
so who's got a question yes what's your
name my man charles bernard traffic CEO
of criteria for success or a sales
improvement company fantastic and we
meld training with a system for selling
and about a year ago 12 months ago i
invested heavily like way beyond what i
thought i should or could in social
media marketing what was in detail what
did you do do you know well first thing
i did is i hired a marketing manager yes
i spent a ton of time interviewing for
the right person i think i got the right
person yes well she does is badger me
every single week yes we should do this
we should we should buy this license we
should spend 12 K on HubSpot we should
be about oh my god in more money more
money and it went I really what
resonated was the the business about
religion because I really did honestly
take a leap of faith I was like I don't
see an ROI you know you're not gonna see
an ROI yes but we got a hundred more
followers this week I'm like where is
that translating to money a hundred what
does that mean right we're business
people here who give the [ __ ] who now
it's 200 a week yeah now we're we're
blowing away our visits Gold's it's
there etc so my question really is did
you sell anything more well we've got a
lot of people no no did you sell more
[ __ ] no right because the person you
hired suck [ __ ]
that was my question with developing a
lot of content you know what you know
what happens have you hired somebody
that's in the job of marketing for the
sake of marketing you just rattled off a
bunch of marketing metrics I don't give
it AI 1.2 million followers on Twitter I
don't give a [ __ ] I like I care about
how it even by [ __ ] when I go sell a
book I want I know that a hundred
thousand then we're gonna buy that's
what I'm excited about I know the other
1.19 ou can create more word-of-mouth
for more people that I can convert she's
rattling off for he I was trying to
follow you there rattling up big money
right
HubSpot on advisor to HubSpot it's a
tool marketers love tools right like
everyone like you can give me the
greatest screwdriver and saw you know
you know these things if you're a good
athlete if something don't you love
those people who buy the best like
tennis I like playing tennis I love my
homies that buy [ __ ] the doll
sneakers
you know [ __ ] joker pads like they
got the federal racketeering they got
all the [ __ ] tools they get in the
court they get smoke six love that's
what I'm worried about with marketers
they want all the tools they want all
the metrics but they don't connect the
pipes to make stuff sell I am only a
Salesman I can sell a lot of stuff for
you because every one of my things is
reverse engineering the sale not the
marketing jargon that is my belief on
your quick listen I have to really like
somebody would have to audit it but when
I hear HubSpot and I hear how many
followers and how much traffic I get
pissed because those are nice marketing
proxies but how many convert is what
matters
well I will say we're getting more
opportunities so the question is that
was really my question where do you do
you see a trend so I'm seeing a trend
right we went from not getting any
opportunities through social media
people are contacting us we never
reached out to don't know where they're
coming from this thing asking for demos
doing a lot of stuff that sounds
promising it is so we're getting what
and we're getting wait a minute did I
pick on the wrong person is she getting
us all the things we need but you guys
are [ __ ] up the clothes
I just don't think it's happening fast
enough I mean it's that I mean I feel
bad now can you apologize for me it's
that it sounds like everybody else's
[ __ ] [ __ ] well you know we're
developing amazing content so my
question really is is oh it's not really
cut it's an observation I'd be curious
on your thoughts yep we're generating so
what I've discovered in this year this
which is a relatively short amount of
time I guess because I've never done it
before is we've parallel streamed I
would say about 20 initiatives yes and
some of them took root and some of them
didn't but they know we're developing
content where in all these platforms you
mentioned yes we're getting we're
getting of downloads where we're getting
forms we're gonna guess so
how long do I have to wait and what do I
have to do you look like it is a very
simple question I think the answer is I
would look at are you getting qualified
leads like those leads I would try to
now first I would look at your content
and I would see if there was a real
right hook at the end of the content to
drive people into a funnel where I could
then convert right is there a phone
number because maybe your demo skews
older and just hitting a phone number
button is a quicker way than filling out
a form I'm always trying to create as
little friction as possible to get to
the sale so first I'd have to look at
the content and see how much friction
there is to get to the funnel then I
need to see what happens when it's in
the funnel is somebody calling them are
they disrespecting the social I mean
look businesses are funny
politics are real maybe the person on
the sales team doesn't like that this
social media person is doing is such a
good good job and they're punting and
lallygagging all those leads and doing
it the old way because they're
uncomfortable with this and maybe not
following up with those leads you got to
look at every piece of the pie to get to
the conversion of the sale but it's not
super hard go audit to see if the stuff
is really getting qualified leads then
go find out what those 90 people what
happened to them like what happened to
Rick Thompson who downloaded a demo and
then put his email and phone number in
what do we do with them that's like
having a store people come to the store
but you close the register so I need to
look at all the pieces of the funnel it
sounds like potentially there's some
stuff brewing but it seems like the
organization since it's so new hasn't
made the connection point from
lead to a sale I mean how long do you
have to wait you have to wait until you
actually have the players in place to
actually close it you might have you
could have waited it could have happened
seven months ago if all the pieces were
talking to each other thank you yeah yes
sir what's your name hey Brian thank you
this is my con I want to make sure
everybody hears it don't know there we
go sorry
no where's my ha the question is it so
company relatively are in our stage of
content marketing so what we do is
provide CFO services for small
medium-sized businesses okay so the big
question is right now we have our own
podcast great we use to try to get our
content out there love that in terms of
living in 2015 yes is that the right
venue I'm a big fan of podcasting and
what about what are you doing about
getting people to listen to the podcast
well we're trying to get interesting
co-hosts that help us and siphon their
audience to be a proxy to get into their
in part and part of its also to show
that you know whether what's hitting
small medium-sized businesses whether
it's a marketing issue social networking
exception so we try to make it
interesting yep from the perspective the
entrepreneur that's right but is that a
better way of doing things is that like
a couple years old or should it be more
about video I wouldn't get hung up on
what's the hottest thing or marking it
you like it podcasting is an absolute
tactic of 2015 tons of people listen to
them how many people here listen to
podcasts it's pretty cool it's a good
number a lot more than three years ago
it had a resurgence it was big and like
Oh a toast at 9:00 now all of a sudden
kind of clicked as our phones got smart
Bluetooth in the car became a big reason
podcast blew up because people just
throwing it from the phone to the car I
think that's a great tactic I'm a little
worried about what you do to get people
to listen to it too many people spend
time of like I mean a podcast yeah I'm
like great what do you want a cookie
like you need you need you need to get
people to listen to it so that it
becomes a proxy content wise to a sale
so Facebook Ads targeting your co-hosts
fans on Facebook yeah we try doing that
we also use our own respective LinkedIn
Network so just use organic when you're
a b2b CFO and a moment to small business
product you're not going to have a lot
of fans so you need to use Facebook Ads
smartly employees of small businesses so
it shows up in their feed
what about
and I'm much higher at this level if
people aren't hardcore knowing that
they're not going to spend a lot of
money I want every penny to count back
to how I grew a three million dollar
businesses the way I built wine library
from three to sixty and five years every
penny was perfect so Facebook is so
disproportionately better than Twitter
right now that I don't even want to have
people go there there's ways to do it
there's a a white listing product I love
where somebody says something nice about
your business you contact them I give
you permission to whitelist it you can
amplify their tweet in ads which is
great because it's third party
endorsement so there's some tactics but
Facebook employees of small businesses
in New Jersey I mean what else do you
[ __ ] want you're not wasting a penny
on distribution you're getting in front
of exactly the right people then they
press play and now the content becomes
the variable if you're good they stay
you can get them if the show sucks
you're in trouble okay
thanks and if you're free for co-hosts
will love to have you all thank you
why'd you let him this go punch him in
the face the customer right [ __ ] hate
customer's always right it's awesome by
the way to that point what would you
listen to from it do you read the email
descends cool have you sent an email
that's hyping the podcast well that's
[ __ ] stupid
I respect that but you're doing a free
podcast for information to make clients
smarter and better feels hard to if you
were charging $4.99 in episode maybe he
could look at it cynically but if it's a
free podcast that has some educational
things that we think will matter to you
I don't see that as selling I see that
as providing value got it how are you my
friend I portray bar Ben Horne president
of Ben Hur Office interior and office
furniture company here in New York loved
it I thought you great by the way thank
you I've been at three or four of these
ready
by far the best talk right you're the
best speaker yeah but um me there's a
lot of midsize businesses here and I'm
sure you have people of making efforts
with social media and everyone's an
expert I don't know who to listen to
that is a problem I have an internship
or Brock
yeah I have an internal marketing person
of an SEO agency I'm confused yeah so
what's the tip of advice it's a it's a
good tip to marking off the balance and
head it to them it's your business right
use me it's your business my business
here's the tip get [ __ ] educated it's
your business spend 50 hours read a
couple books there's this crazy site
called YouTube it's free you can watch
videos you have to be educated it's no
different than somebody standing up and
saying oh man I'm getting really hosed
by my CFO or finances because you
weren't educated about your finances
like this is a this is a core skill
that's needed and either your get lucky
and you somebody you trust with your
life
because that's what your business is you
let them run it or you get educated so
that when you ask a question your SEO
firm is running most of its ads against
your own company's name on Google and so
you're probably spending half your money
on people that would have come to you
anyway like you need to become a
practitioner you know it's no different
than being good enough to pick good
furniture if you were bad at that your
business would be over I would beam
specially for selling b2b product for
you not to be a practitioner of how
you're actually getting
and leads in that environment is a
vulnerability right I'm sure cataloging
and phone calls you know that's how you
built it me too the problem is you can
save a lot of money away from that stuff
if you've learned this so go to Turks
and Caicos for four days take your
laptop use the Wi-Fi read a couple books
watch 18 seminars and get educated and
then have a smart conversation
I mean it's so funny all my friends ask
me they all have businesses like I don't
get it like then put it in the work or
don't and let it be a vulnerability you
can roll the way you want to but that is
the answer yeah I'm gonna go all the way
over there announcer on how long how are
you get a mic out I could you can't hear
me I can hear him oh what's your name
jeonggi lovely ladies of me I said no
you don't mic good night
John Greenhut first of all I never
really cursed but that was [ __ ] great
I'm glad I could inspire who are the
[ __ ] man like really good now you're
rolling keep going so just to simplify
this because that you know it's a huge
world out there in you know in web
marketing yes I guess if I was going to
ask you one simple question what would
be top three things on Facebook
advertising or just Facebook marketing
that you would suggest to everyone here
what do you what would your what's your
business or what do you do for my market
nutritional supplements skin care teeth
whitening products TV radio or online
Jesus Christ yeah you can just you can
kill oh really you can literally think
about this so how do you spend keep the
mic how do you spend your money now all
three infomercials no short form short
form and uh what's the rest uh radio
television internet marketing and what's
the internet basically SEM Google
Adwords
uh no we were banner again I need to
educate myself Chris no ever we're doing
everything from blogging yeah the bottom
line is you could literally and you know
what the couple so here's a good example
you know what your products compete with
right like you know your products and
you know what the other big products are
in the category right you can literally
market against people that are fans of
that product and have your story video
or print
which is picture or video and Facebook
and people actually see it because it's
in their stream so you can create
segmentations you could create a
segmentation of if you want to market if
you're teeth whitening product is doing
super well in whatever category you're
knowledgeable about if you're trying to
reach a sixty year eight year old male
who's drank coffee his whole life versus
a 25 year old Upper East Side female
you've got to tell them two different
stories
that's why Facebook is so powerful we
can segment that scale so the right
tactic is create as many segmentations
as you possibly can afford that target
customers and then tell stories to them
that matter to them means it everybody
is like guys T me and general marketing
is all vanilla because it's trying to
reach everybody or you can run an ad for
teeth whitening - 25 to 29 year old
asian-americans and go figure this is
mind-blowing maybe there's an Asian
American man in the picture like you
want to sell me [ __ ]
talk about the Jets if you sell peanut
butter put a Facebook post with some
peanut butter and a [ __ ] Jets hat
I'll buy it
so it's not just demo you know it's not
just why does be et over-index with
african-americans in viewership they're
in it like it's crazy like we can mark
it so smartly so learn how segmentation
works what's crazier that will blow your
mind is they'll cost you a hundred or
two hundred dollars per group to see
meaningful things happen if your
contents right and then you win if your
products right but like the exercise and
supplement amulet that's the only people
I mean you should be buying Instagram
ads yesterday that's all that's going on
on Instagram Instagram is basically soft
porn of fitness people I like all the
dudes laughed you [ __ ] scum buckets
thank you yes hi Ted Goldberg Aileen
candles were a domestic manufacturer
comment first and then a question um I
spent way too much money retail at your
place you can't get in on the weekends I
would knock down that Taco Bell and make
it into a parking trust me yeah it was a
beta thank you so where do you live I
live in New York City and Tewksbury New
Jersey thank you so much for your
halfway and I spend way too much money
really love you so much and there's a
bunch of us here that will uh collect a
fund to displace Woody Johnson to jet we
missed that we missed those ads on the
Jersey Turnpike if you're taking over
the Jets and that's fun like he's
referring to Iran billboard ads on
Jersey Turnpike for Wine Library and
Wine Library TV I did a show on YouTube
a couple months after you two K out that
maybe kind of internet famous like I
know the arbitrage of print radio
television Direct Mail I spent on it
heavily and understood it compared to
the alternatives now keep call my friend
um so what you said about people
completely resonates from my partner
night um we we are right now trying to
get a grasp and you didn't mention glass
store yes we're really trying to get a
grasp on kind of the message we're
exiting out found in terms of attracting
I'm gonna throw four people I'm gonna
throw you for such a loop in a minute
good ok um let me get right into it how
many people are familiar with what glass
door is cool so so weird
going to get a handle right now we have
a lot of factory workers hire our what
furnace I'm going to drive three people
so we're dealing with minimum age weight
minimum wage workers so Yelp Facebook
yep blast or we're trying to both
attract really talented people and all
levels and we're trying to kind of exude
and combat some of the negativities
written because we have minimum wage
employer employees kind of can you just
comment on the whole can outbound and
company image through glass door yes for
Facebook and the like yes so I'm very
passionate about this yet so every
single employee that we fire at
vaynermedia that is not self-aware and
didn't heed to the 30
I mean Oh James Orsini where are you
James please stand up James please tell
this room how shitty I am at keeping
employees around way too long and giving
them way too much chance that [ __ ] up
our cash flow and our profit margin like
the worst you've ever seen right good
I'm the worst
like I love employees literally the most
and I give them 47,000 chances to figure
it out but when we fire them if they're
still like what the [ __ ] I'm like
I literally tell them to leave a
negative review on Glassdoor if they
believe that so I would tell you that I
think vaynermedia's Glassdoor review is
disproportionately worse than its
reality because I have no interest in
anybody applying for my company if they
believe in anonymous reviews on the
internet so I would spin this
conversation a little bit backwards
there's a lot of 10 years worth of Yelp
data and a lot of other data that points
to a unbelievable distrust to anonymous
reviews versus the establishment now the
reason I can win is because I put out so
much content that I've built out equity
instead of going on the defense against
Yelp and Glassdoor I want you to go on
the offense to the world by putting out
content got it it's changing the
conversation in your mind from a
defensive one to an offensive one you
like it right exactly yeah yep just
looking good yeah hi hi darlin Deb
DiGregorio camera I've been marketing
tech companies for over 30 years
amazing nice to meet you right nice to
meet you too right down the road from
you in Maplewood we do business strategy
marketing and technology we talked about
getting educated yeah so here's the
shameless hussy plug do it this is a
book I just wrote yes 30 years of
brilliance in it yes to our well on our
list think it's brilliance let me be the
judge of that sorry go ahead okay okay
you can be the judge now go ahead right
gonna call triumph over toothpicks
the essential guide to business in the
digital age you and I are very much on
sync so I'm going to answer your
question before you even ask it how am i
selling it first standing up here
shamelessly and Hawking it to everybody
in the room everybody respects that cuz
we don't have a second
um Facebook Ads go bigger go figure and
sending them direct to Amazon or Barnes
& Noble and especially Amazon works
great so have you started trying it are
you in is Instagram still in beta right
there I think it's sir I'm still
Instagram is going to open up you like I
know
Instagram is going to be a beast
for you the book sales that are
happening organically on Instagram or
overwhelming the other thing you may
want to do is go to Instagram search
specific hashtags that you think will be
relevant and reach out to individuals
you can pay as little as twenty five to
fifty dollars for a sponsored post where
they'll take a post of it make sure that
they put out hashtag sponsored so it's
not doesn't feel inauthentic or and I
think you could do really well well take
you you're welcome a kid yeah let me go
let me go over there back there hey
darlin hello hello hi my name is deepali
I'm from precision technologies and I'm
wondering what's your opinion about
social media marketing for b2b
businesses I think it's a good market
any fee s then how what did you say I
think it's a good [ __ ] idea yeah
because you said everybody has their
smart ones what are you guys what's what
himself IT staffing services great who
do you sell to CTO CIOs yes great make a
video that the opening line says does
your CIO know make it 49 seconds don't
talk about your product make it about
the thesis of your world then deploy it
against employees of the companies that
you want to sell to that cio and CTO
will have five emails in his or her
inbox the next morning for people that
work at DuPont GE small businesses or
whoever the hell your target is in 24
hours for a couple of hundred bucks you
know what that's called practitioner
ship okay and and and and the reason I'm
making a big point about this is what I
just told her Anna is right make content
that targets the person that makes the
business decision start the creative in
the copy of does your CTO know then tell
your story for a minute and then deploy
it for a hundred bucks against the
employees of a company which is one of
the segmentations that you can run ads
against in a facebook world it shows up
in a feed I go hi I work at this company
I don't know Rick noses share center
Rick now Rick knows five people tell him
he's curious he comes into your
that's a good idea no [ __ ] thank you hon
let's put it on
can you check if her likes on okay there
we go
what's your name Malou Walker how are
you of matrix initiatives were the
company that makes and markets Zicam
great get to shorten the duration of a
cold I think we're also a client so
you've talked all today about outgoing
messages and how we can place our
messages going out yes and we do a lot
of that and we do a lot of Facebook
posts and the whole thing but I'm also
interested in is there a way is there a
technology or process where we can get
information in so we do lots of
traditional market research yes you know
we do a lot of people on my team spent a
lot of time just reading a lot yes and
paying attention on to social media and
just trying to understand our consumer
yes I'm far more interested in what my
consumer is doing now and how she's
segmented now and how a big market
research study could tell me how they're
segmented in understanding I love with
the white spaces and is there is there a
organized way we can pull that in
through um so you did you me yeah so
what you're referring to like so first
of all this is a tremendous question so
thank you there's unbelievable amounts
of market research available for free
now compared to paying Boston Consulting
a million dollars to tell you so
obviously the lowest hanging fruit is
Twitter search right so twitter.com
slash search and putting in keywords is
stunning IP right now there's listening
tools radian6 salesforce products where
you can pay a lot of money that scrapes
big data and formulates it I'm actually
going to throw you for a loop and kind
of similar to like reframing the
question on the Glassdoor question I get
most of my market research by creating
content that leads the conversation in
the comments section to a question or
insight that I'm looking forward to see
what I mean
so if you made content around what a
mother does who has two
children and works a full-time job and
then created a poll or LED the sentence
be finished by their comments and then
targeted women with two children that
have professions or your own CRM
database you can extract exactly what
you're looking for when you present it
in a way where it's content and fun and
interesting enough value and lightweight
and that's one of my favorite favorite
ways to get consumer insights at scale
because then when I get a question
organically that I like I'll amplify it
with ads to hit meaningful scale to
really get a proxy make sure I'm not
just speaking within an eco and then
there's the rating sixes and all those
other listening tools that are out there
that can give you that proxy as well so
they call ground signal that I'm an
investor in that I'm obsessed with that
searches Instagram photos and comments
because that's a new place where a lot
of millennial moms are spending their
time so I think you know there's some
tools out there as I'm sure you're
probably where you can go freehand and
use the new Facebook search and the
really established well-planted twitter
search or you could start making content
on your own platforms that leads them to
the well of an insight and then amplify
it with smart targeted ads you're
welcome yo hi Gary I'm Peter Bell I'm
the president CEO of Eden autism
services which is an agency down in
Princeton Univ near Princeton University
but Princeton New Jersey my question has
to do more about what is your advice to
us as CEOs about our own personal
profiles on Facebook Twitter Instagram
snapchat and all those kinds of things
I have always avoided the friend request
from the family or the mom whose kid
goes to my school or even staffed and so
forth I was intrigued by the fact that
your Facebook friends with all of your
employees and so forth how do you
differentiate your professional life
from your personal life do I really want
people to know that I was out cheering
my daughter on for La Crosse over the
weekend or what I had for dinner the
other night because it was just so great
and so forth yeah how do you how would
you advise all of us to have
so first of all most on Facebook if you
want to create a public persona version
of yourself you can create a Facebook
fan page and drive everybody towards
their you set an autoresponder on those
requests on your personal Facebook page
hold on to the mic for a second because
it might be a follow up and you could
drive them there the other thing is you
just may feel comfortable and showing
that part of your life I still think
that people do business with people and
that if you both like Rubio or if you
both like the Jets or things that make
sure that stuff matters I don't think
every CEO should be on I remember there
was a big trend in 2008-9 on Twitter
every CEO needs to be on Twitter I think
that's a mistake because I think a lot
of CEOs are not cool and nice and
interesting people right so like if you
know that you're introverted and don't
like engaging with people why put
yourself in a place where you do that at
scale but I think it's an individual at
the end of day it's an individual
decision um I think there's way more
benefits nobody's making you post
content right yeah I'm stunningly out
there it's very difficult to find
pictures of my two children because I've
made that choice um I can text pictures
to my mom or you know what I mean so I
think it's a personal choice I think I
think most people are leaving a lot of
upside on the table by closing it off
because there's a lot of other ways to
communicate to the actual six people
that you give a [ __ ] about than just
Facebook and so that's my answer
thank you I know I'm over so that's that
guys thank you